[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i bet your boys going through that right
now who's that dustin
oh yeah i'm sure oh i know he's been
hacked yeah people been trying to get
him to do everything he said stop yeah
driving gloves he said somebody hit him
up to model driving gloves i'm like
jesus man for golf huh no for driving
autos bro like like the taxi kept
driving like new york like roaring 20s
kind of [ __ ]
whenever i get into a tax cab the guy
gloves i was like bro we're about to be
early
this guy came
ready to work bro
who's playing
dude how strenuous is holding the wheel
we got power steering now dude
people drive with their knees dude
people who have no arms and they go to
work by driving with their [ __ ] feet
and you got full-on gloves
to hold the wheel the wheel is made out
of gloves they made it easier for you
they just put the glove on the wheel
it's unbelievable
what could it possibly do i don't know
after a long day drive you think you
take it off you're like thank god
i'm sweating
but i think they're waiting to help you
like get like yeah no he's wearing
weighted driving have you [ __ ] seen
america talk
people are wearing complete [ __ ]
there was a weighted swimming neck brace
that two people [ __ ] drowned in that
they had a lawsuit like eight years ago
why would anybody
wear weights in the pool because they're
[ __ ] idiots here have you been alive
have you [ __ ] been outside of your
eyes
no people are [ __ ] bro
awaited swimming to fight people are
legally [ __ ] and then there's people
that are just after that yo that's the
thing that's crazy is it like we have to
decide when a [ __ ] starts right and
there are people who are just not
recording yeah we call them normal dude
there's no that yeah that first the
first little iq point right there those
people walking around barely getting by
yeah
like every once in a while want to make
one of them moans and little [ __ ]
jurassic park
there is a guy okay alan his parents
just
let him go outside and just [ __ ]
turn around and just look at each other
[Laughter]
they gotta hold in that [ __ ] sound so
nobody knows they gotta hold that [ __ ]
out yeah just looking around
[Music]
it's like a mosquito
fire your manager yeah i don't have a
manager now either you don't need a
babysitter
what we need are producers
right right like we need i don't know if
that's your role but like
i need i have a guy who does all my
video nick very questionable role but
also
has done a great job in helping me you
know build what's going on yeah
especially for a premature
very so i'm saying dude just do my best
every day we don't have
post mature babies
he could have gone post if you wanted to
i think he came out early because he was
curious go and post that's [ __ ] we've
got to look into that like 10 months
11. dude comes out with dreads full hair
yeah
black dudes come out late i can imagine
that like damn he's supposed to be here
on wednesday you know
he shows up with two other black dudes
you're like
y'all didn't know they were down here
with me hey we were just kicking it bro
when you think about it we just talk
[ __ ] for hours and that's better
than
a tv show that they spend tens of
millions of dollars yeah like you and i
have just made [ __ ] sounds there was a
part of this podcast where we just made
restart sounds i made one but yeah but
you did a couple because you did you did
a couple you did more you did the most
yeah you did the baritone take that king
of the sting okay you eat your weird
foods we're out here and we're making
retards
you guys are bad friends
get the [ __ ] out of here you guys are
both two guys that i told i wouldn't do
podcasts with that's who you guys are
so let's
that's
[ __ ]
bobby lee you're taking that
santina are you taking that bobby lee's
not even awake right now and it's 4 p.m
in the afternoon guy texted me at 2 49
a.m the other day asking me a normal
daytime question
what do you ask
i love that [ __ ] so much i
haven't seen you in a while yeah
the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's because i'm [ __ ] dayternal fam
do you think black people are better at
being broke than white people i think
broke people are better at being broke
yeah it's just simple like if you know
anybody that's broke
they still got [ __ ] yeah sorry i know
you don't use these words we can use
[ __ ] okay don't use it a ton okay
they still got please show me anything i
mean
i got you okay
i they still
got friends yeah they still got jokes oh
dude being poor was fun dude we used to
burn everything in the [ __ ] ditch bro
bro people can't do that that's a fire
if you don't hear it that's cruel when
you're poor nobody [ __ ] even comes
it's true people used to call the cops
all the time and they would never come
do they come a month later yeah
dude being poor in a lot of ways is
better because you got hope yeah
somewhere to go somewhere right it's
like yo one day we're gonna be rich and
we're just gonna have our own ditch yeah
in our backyard we could just burn all
the [ __ ] we weren't gonna have a
shelving unit yeah dude i remember
wanting a [ __ ] shelving unit in my
[ __ ] room like [ __ ] did you
get that no we didn't get it but now i
have one
yeah but i remember dude somebody from
the [ __ ]
somebody would drive by and throw dead
animal some veterinarian who was saving
money cutting corners yeah throw dead
animals in a ditch so we'd be out there
throwing [ __ ] calf vertebraes at each
other and [ __ ] fun and playing football
with like a cossacks of some kind of
damn animal if you're rich peta comes
for you yeah you're rich that's a
[ __ ] crime sucks that's forensic
fauzi that's american greed dude it
really is what does every serial killer
do it kills [ __ ] animals yeah right
that's that you're describing the
behavior
but when you're poor it's just fun and
here we are yeah go deep dude i gotta
sternum yeah you know go deep it was
just a different
tell me if this is racist or not dude
cause you're the closest thing you're
the closest thing we've had to a black
guest in a while dude
is the us postal system basically just
like giving mail to a black guy and
hoping it gets where it's supposed to go
that's what i feel like
that's what i realized the other day
that the u.s postal system
today is basically just like hand in the
middle to a black eye
and hoping he cares enough for it to go
where it's supposed to go
is that not [ __ ] the truth
like go
mail something bro
[Applause]
go mail something
yeah you might be on
man no homo or nothing but like
it's [ __ ] crazy bro
what if once you get lost bro
i mean this it's just a lot of things
right right bro u.s postal system [ __ ]
is
this doesn't work and they're like stop
stop
and he was like he's like no you
understand like it's just handing it to
a black guy and maybe he brings it and
then they're like stop
trying to make it better you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you thinking he's like
but maybe there's a better system even
for them like we could give them an
address or something to get your postage
to and america's like [ __ ]
you
for wanting us to get our mail
piece of [ __ ] yeah are you crazy guy
dude the anxiety of you want a white
male [ __ ] traveling around the
country anymore
this [ __ ] has to stop dude but just
imagine being that poor black guy they
just give you a satchel full of [ __ ] and
they're like do you know where where any
of this should go
deliver it yeah but i was just wondering
if if i should
should know where is there like a route
dude how many black dudes out there are
just pretending there's santa every day
and just [ __ ] putting mail wherever
bro how many [ __ ]
bro
bro
have you ever seen it like a mailbox
you're racist or not bro have you ever
seen them will they just let us know
every day i go to my mailbox and i'm
thinking there's going to be a letter
and it's just going to say yes or no
but it never comes
just tell us man
that was a good laugh
it was a good laugh man
yeah there's a guy who always sends me
snaps of him doing cocaine from scotland
all the time that's what's up i guess we
got covered all the time and then they
honestly just stopped like abruptly
so i hope that that guy honestly is
doing okay yeah
there could be a horrible
yeah jotty i think was the guy's name
and i hope he's doing all right um
because they suddenly [ __ ] stopped it
and he was doing a lot
like a lot it took some of the snaps
were long oh
so
well that's the other thing that like
people on the coast don't realize is it
like you can call it rural but like
rural america
has the attitude of they don't know
better right we think that like and i'm
guilty of this back in the day before i
kind of really started traveling the
country we think that like oh they're
too stupid to even know to make fun of
them and rural america is like oh let's
say they just don't know any better it's
they don't know any better they don't
know that literally is it they haven't
been home in a few years that's what
they think you know it's sad nobody's
cooked for them in a while you know
nobody cares about them
we're both they're all in lawsuits yes
yeah a hundred percent i agree you
saying that
makes all those people
feel
like defended
and you're not you're saying in a way
where like coastal people laugh too
right because you're this all you're all
in lawsuits that's a funny line yeah to
make fun of somebody who thinks that
they're living the life and it's like
you haven't seen a tree in a week yeah
you haven't walked on grass yeah i
didn't know about grass yeah i didn't
know about grass yeah until i was like
10. crabgrass is tricky but the other
they got good grass out there still just
with grass grass yeah i'm working on it
no if you're doing grass grass you're
doing good okay crabgrass is like is
this i just don't even know what that is
rope yeah it's like grass and rope kind
of mixed together ah sounds horrible
it's bad but i mean it's useful like if
you're trying to make something i grew
up in a community where they the the
when they had the vaccine for polio they
created it in my community in louisiana
and it gave cervical cancer to millions
of women millions of women in america
but the government had already made it
they'd already created and spent all the
money to make so much of it that they
had the
because it also got rid of polio but
the cost was your [ __ ] got to get taken
out
you know what i'm saying i don't have a
[ __ ] man
i'm gonna be honest with you that
doesn't sound like a problem
as a non-owner
[Laughter]
they out there stealing bugattis
and they got a new guy
[ __ ] son that's all my bro how great is
six nine all he does is he walks into a
[ __ ] uh he walked in with johnson and
murphy at the airport he's like y'all
[ __ ] son
meek million [ __ ] i love it look at
this go right here bro that's who drops
more in bombs than anybody i've ever met
the most
have you been somewhere like that and
performed somewhere rural i went to i
went to fairbanks did you yeah yeah yeah
it sucked did it it sucked what was it
was it that's why it sucked were you
hunting chicks do you go hunting chicks
when you go what are you doing i had i
brought a girl with me
uh but like it sucked because
everything that i wanted out of alaska
wasn't really there
it was just another city
it just happened to be cold as [ __ ]
right like i wanted the you know the
yukon or whatever that [ __ ] is i wanted
to see the bears the gold rolling down
the hill all of it yeah i was excited
sam and jumping in your shirt while
you're walking down the street whoa
this is sick
fresh right out there yeah i didn't see
it the same as drinking [ __ ] fresh
water that's what they do yeah
and they didn't have it none of it oh
dude
no that's not true maybe it is
i guess fish die of thirst when they're
out of that's really what kills them
yeah but the good ones [ __ ] go hard
dude the clint eastwood's a fish they're
out there for a day or two they could
yeah not even wobbling just having a
[ __ ] cigarette
adjust their tail
i'm not gonna flop
[Music]
just the wrong way i know
[Music]